opengl can be used to create complex
graphics effects
this advanced opengl course from victor
gordon
will take your skills to the next level
hi everyone
in this course i'll teach you about
different advanced topics in opengl that
will help you achieve more complex
effects
better looking renders and more
optimized scenes
if you don't know what opengl is or are
not familiar with it
then you should first watch the
beginners course for opengl
which you can find on this channel and
that should be all you need to know
about this course enjoy
in this tutorial we'll have a look at
the depth buffers in opengl
and also see how we can make use of them
for a little graphical effect
you might remember that we've already
made use of the diff buffer
in the going 3d tutorial in order to fix
a weird issue we had
since the buffer is turned off by
default we want to make sure we have it
enabled
and that we clear it each frame just
like the color buffer
now what this buffer basically does is
that it stores depth values
that represent how far away from the
near plane of the projection matrix a
certain fragment
is a depth value of 0 meaning that it's
right on the near plane
end of 1 meaning that it's on the far
plane
using this depth information we can
assess which object should be in front
of which other object
we can do this by using the gel depth
function and
inserting one of the following inputs by
default opengl chooses gls
which means that if the depth value of
an object
is less than that of the current def
value then the first value replaces the
second
in most circumstances you should use gls
but i suppose you could also choose one
of the others if you want your game or
application to be mind-bending now the
cool part let's
visualize the diff buffer we can easily
do this by going to the fragment shader
and outputting glfrac coordinates dot z
as the fractal the problem is
that as soon as we press run you'll
notice that the screen is mostly pure
white
the only way to see a bit of darkness is
to get very close to an object
this is due to the fact that the depth
in opengl is not linear
if the depth was linear then we would
have the same amount of
precision for depth at a close distance
as we would at a far away distance since
we almost
always focus on things that are close to
us
we want to make the precision be very
high near us
and low away from us this is achieved by
using
this formula don't worry we don't have
to implement it
since opengl does it automatically
sometimes though you want to use another
formula
so in order to do that we must first get
the z value by
linearizing the depth function which can
be done using this function
now using this function we get the z
value which keep in mind
is not normalized this value is simply
the distance from the near plane so
let's declare the near and far constants
of our frustum and divide the linear
depth by the forward length to quickly
normalize it
just to see what the results look like
now let's just look at the quick problem
you can get and then i'll show you the
cool effect we can achieve with depth
buffers
so the main issue that arises from def
buffers
is called z fighting and it occurs
because
two or more triangles have the same
depth buffer
and thus the dip function can't decide
which one is closer than the other
and thus it keeps changing between them
constantly
an easy fix to this is usually to make
sure you don't have triangles that are
too close to one another
and parallel if z fighting appears at a
far away distance then you might also
consider tweaking the function of the
diff buffer
so that you have more precision at that
distance
and the final trick is to use a bigger
integer for the depth buffer
usually by default it uses 24 bits but
you could change it to 32 bits if your
card supports it
this will increase the precision and
thus decrease the chance of z
fighting now for the cool effect we can
take the z value and plug it into a
logistic function
for which we have a steepness parameter
and an offset parameter
the stiffness will control how fast the
depth value changes from close to 0
to close to 1 and the offset will
determine
at what z value this change is halfway
done
the cool thing about this is that this
can give you smooth edges for the end of
your frustum
if you want that but the even nicer
thing is that this can somewhat simulate
a fog effect
so let's change our background color to
a gray and calculate the depth value
using our function
then multiply our usual direct light by
the reverse of our depth value
and also add the depth value times the
gray color from before
now we should have a nice simple fog
effect keep in mind
that you might need to adjust the
stiffness and offset a bit to get it
just right have fun playing around with
different effects
in this tutorial we'll take a look at
the stencil buffer and how we can use it
to create useful effects
such as outlining a model so the stencil
buffer
just like the diff buffer holds the
value for each pixel you can see
these values being used for image
masking in general
unlike the diff buffer though where each
pixel holds between
2 and 4 bytes of data for the stencil
buffer each pixel holds one byte of data
so values from 0 to 255
but you'll mainly only use the values of
0
and 1. so let's look at how we can work
with this new buffer
first of all we have the function gl
stencil mask that allows us to choose
which parts of the stencil buffer we
want to be able to modify
it simply takes a pixel from the mask
and the corresponding pixel from the
stencil buffer
and applies a bitwise and comparison
on them keep in mind each pixel has a
byte of data
so it beats a bitwise and operation
compares each bit with its corresponding
counterpart
and only outputs 1 if they're both 1.
therefore
if we input 0x0 into gl stencil mask
which means that we have 8 bits equal to
0 then all the comparisons will fail and
the stencil buffer won't change
at all but if we input 0xff
into gel stencil mask then all the bits
of the mask will be
1 since 0xff is equal to 8
once and so we'll be able to modify any
part of the stencil buffer now let's
look at two more functions we can make
use of
geo stencil func and gel stencil op gl
stencil func
allows us to control how the stencil
buffer passes the test or fills the test
while gel stencil op allows us to
dictate what happens when the stencil
test fails when the stencil test passes
by the div test
fails and when both pass let's take a
deeper look at gl stencil func
it takes in three arguments a function a
reference value
and a mask the function can be one of
these by default being set to gel always
so the test always passes the reference
value
is simply the value we used to compare
in the function
notice how before comparing the stencil
value with the reference value we apply
a bitwise and
operation to both using the mask this
means that if we want to compare the
numerical value of the two
accurately you will want your mask to be
0xff
so that nothing changes now for gl
stencil op
it has three arguments as fail dp
fail and dp pass this stands for stencil
fill depth fill and depth path for all
of these you can choose between the
following
options by default they all have gl keep
which basically means that nothing
changes
there is not really much more to say
about these functions so
if you want to know more about them look
them up in the documentation
the stencil buffer can be used for many
things such as portals mirrors
and more but an easy feature to
implement is outlining of models
so let's take a look at that we first
want to render our object like we
normally do
and update the stencil buffer with once
everywhere we have a fragment from our
object and zero everywhere we do not
have a fragment from our object
this will essentially create a figure
like this
then we want to disable writing to the
stencil buffer so we do not
accidentally modify it and also disable
diff testing
so that we can make sure the next object
we draw will be completely in front of
the previous one
now we want to render a scaled up
version of the object we had before
but this time in a flat color and with
the following condition
we only its fragments where the stencil
value is not
one so basically not where the
silhouette of the previous object was
then we just restore writing to the
stencil and enable
the div buffer again that's all we have
to do now let's implement it in code we
start off by enabling our stencil buffer
using gel enable gl stencil test and
making sure we also have our div
buffer enabled then we use gl stencil op
plugging in gl keep gl keep and dual
replace
this will make it so that when both the
diff and
stencil tests pass we'll use the
reference values specified by gel
essential function
now let's make sure we clear all the
buffers before
each frame and go on to the part where
the magic happens
first we specify our stencil test always
passes and set the reference value to 1.
then we enable writing to all of our
stencil buffer with a stencil mask of
all ones and now we simply draw our
object
by this point in time our stencil buffer
looks like this
and our color buffer looks like this
remember that all these values
are 1 because we specified in the gl
stencil
op function that if both the stencil
and the test pass then make the pixel of
the stencil buffer equal to one
now for the outline we want our stencil
test to only pass when it's not equal to
1
and the def test passes then we disable
our div buffer for previously mentioned
reasons
and disable writing to the stencil mask
so we can keep our original silhouette
now
since we want to make the outline of
flat color we'll have to create two new
shaders and the shader program so let's
first create the shader program
like so then for outlining that frag we
simply want to return a color
while for outlining that word we want to
get a position
and all the uniforms related to
transformations
plus a new float uniform called
outlining which will multiply with the
scale matrix
now back in the main function we'll want
to send that outlining uniform to the
shader with a value of something like
1.08 then we simply draw the same object
again
but this time using the other shaders
the last step we need to do
is to enable writing to the whole
stencil clear it by always passing the
test and replacing the values with 0
and enabling the diff buffer now if you
run the program you should see
an outline around your object if your
object has its origin at its geometrical
center
and if it doesn't have very complex
shapes then the outline probably looks
fine
in my case though you can see that the
origin is not at the center
since the outline is skewed upwards and
that
the shapes are pretty complex with many
curves
therefore this method won't work that
well a better method that doesn't take
much
would be to import the normals in the
vertex shader
and add these to the position vector
multiplying them by the outlining which
will remove from the scale matrix and
which will now lower from 1.08
to 0.08 now when scaling the vectors
instead of scaling them from their
origin we are
sort of scaling them outwardly from the
model
using the normal as a reference for what
outward
means this will give you much better
results with one exception
if you have hard edges then your normals
will be close to perpendicular to one
another
and so will create a little gap when
expanding the model
therefore a third solution to this would
be to simply have another model
that's bigger than the first one to be
more specific
it has to be thicker not necessarily
bigger
you can achieve something like this
using blender's solidify
modifier here you can see i have the
initial model
and the bigger version of it now i've
already exported
both as different models and i only have
to import them into my program like so
then instead of drawing the object the
second time i simply draw the bigger
version of
it this time not even needing a uniform
to scale it
and as you can see this gives the best
results though
at the cost of doubling the storage cost
you could of course make a function
similar to the solidify function that
blender has
but that would be a bit slightly more
complicated for this tutorial
today i'll show you what face calling is
and how it affects performance
we are also going to measure this
performance change by making an
fps counter so face culling is a step in
the graphics pipeline that decides if a
triangle will move on to the fragment
shader
aka if the triangle will be drawn or not
opengl decides this by seeing which side
of the triangle
is currently facing the camera generally
speaking in most 3d graphics programs it
is the front side of a triangle that is
sent to the fragment shader and the back
side of a triangle that is discarded the
way
opengl figures out which side is which
is by an
index convention which can either be
clockwise or
counterclockwise in a counterclockwise
framework if the order of the indices of
a triangle
are counterclockwise when facing us then
the side we see
is the front side likewise if the order
of the indices of a triangle
are clockwise when facing us then the
sideways c
is the back side for a clockwise
framework it's the exact opposite
most graphic programs use a counter
clockwise standard but don't expect all
of them to use this
now in order to put all of this into
code we just have to enable the face
calling using gel enable with gl
call face specify which face we want to
keep
99 percent of the time that will be gl
front and then specify the standard we
want to use
again i suggest using the counter
clockwise one since from what i've seen
is more common than the clockwise one
now if we run the program you'll notice
that when we get inside an
object we won't be able to see its
insides since it contains the box of the
triangles
which it discarded therefore we only see
the background
so let's see if this makes any
difference in performance
for that we'll need an fps counter which
i'll display in the title of the window
let's start by creating three doubles
for the previous time
the current time and the difference of
these two then we also want an
unsigned integer that will act as a
counter to see how many frames we have
in a certain amount of time
now fps is simply the amount of frames
you get in a second
so that means that in order to get the
fps
we can count the number of frames we get
in a second a frame being one loop in
our main while loop but that would also
mean that our fps will get
updated only once a second instead let's
update it every 30th of a second for
example
to do that we just need to get the
current time in seconds using glfw
get time the time difference and
increment the counter
then if the difference is higher or
equal to a thirtieth of a second
we go ahead with the measurement of the
fps the fps will simply be equal to one
divided by the time difference
which is just the amount of frames in a
second that this time difference gives
but the time difference contains
multiple frames which are equal to the
counter
so we also need to multiply it with the
counter as well
now we could stop here but it's also
useful to know how long
a frame takes in terms of milliseconds
to do that we simply divide the time
difference by the counter
which gives us the number of seconds a
frame takes and then multiply it out by
a thousand to transform it into
milliseconds
then we simply put together the new
title and apply to the window using glfw
set window title then we want to set the
previous time as the current time
in order to get the time difference back
to 0 and also set the counter to 0.
now if you start your program you'll be
able to see the amount of frames you
have
if they are stuck on 60 then that means
that you have vsync on
which race to keep your fps constant to
60 frames per second
if you wish to disable this then write
glfw
swap interval 0 in your main function
keep in mind that this will only be able
to deactivate vsync if fissing is not
forced by your graphics driver in any
case i recommend keeping it at 60 frames
per second but if you don't want to do
that
at least make sure that the functions
that handle user inputs are put into an
if statement that works periodically
like this one
otherwise the responsiveness of your
inputs will vary with your fps which you
do not want
and just to show that face calling
improves your fps here is a very high
resolution model
and the difference in fps the difference
is not
big here but it's noticeable in the
numbers
when you have multiple models and a lot
of stuff happening the difference will
become even more noticeable
in this tutorial i'll show you how to
quickly get transparency turned on and
also how to make use of the blending
feature in
opengl so as you might have noticed all
the textures we've been using so far
had four components red green blue
and alpha rgba the first three of these
give color to our scene
while the last one controls the level of
transparency
different objects have now if you look
at this grass model i have imported
you'll notice that there is no
transparency to it to enable that
we simply have to create a new fragment
shader which will be
identical to our normal fragment shader
but
we'll check if the alpha value is
smaller than a certain threshold
and if it is we'll discard that fragment
don't forget to also make a new shader
program
for this new fragment shader so if you
run the program you should see the grass
is now
as it should be now i'll just add a
bunch of randomly placed transparent
windows
since the code here is not relevant to
opengl
i won't be explaining it the shader i
use for this
is a very basic shader that just
displays the textures without
any lighting so now as you can see there
are a bunch of
windows but even though in my texture
they are see-through
here they are not in order to achieve a
see-through effect
we need blending now for a bit of theory
this is the formula opengl uses for
blending different colors together
all the c terms stand for color while
the t
terms stand for transparency which in
case you didn't know or forgot
an alpha value of 0 is fully transparent
and an alpha value of 1 is fully opaque
and then the source color is the color
in the fragment shader
while the destination color is the color
in the color buffer
these transparencies can have different
formulas the most common one
is that in which the source gets its
transparency value from the alpha part
of the source color
while the destination's transparency is
1
minus the alpha value of the source so
now let's tell opengl we want to use
this configuration using gel blend func
specifying the source and destination
functions
here is a list of some functions you
might want to use for one reason
or another then if you want to you can
also use gel blend equation with one of
these
arguments in order to specify how you
want the previous colors to interact
basically changing the default equation
and lastly you can use the gel blend
func separate function
to choose how to interact with the rgb
channel
and the alpha channel for both the
source and destination
keep in mind that you can't specify a
function for
each rgb value only for all of them
together
at this point we just have to enable
blending using gel enable gl blend
right before our windows and then
disable it
right after we are done drawing them so
that we don't accidentally affect
anything else
you should always do this with
transparent objects
after that just compile and you should
see that the windows are transparent
but there is one problem the blending
is all messed up it just doesn't look
right
and for that we have our friend the
depth buffer to blame since the windows
are drawn in random order
windows that are drawn behind already
existing ones
don't get wrong at all since the depth
test
fails so in order to draw all the
windows we should draw the furthest one
first
and the closest one last or you could of
course be lazy about it
and simply disable the diff buffer when
drawing the windows
but that will not work in most
circumstances
and i would not recommend it usually
another option would be to sort the
windows by their distance from the
camera
now sorting has nothing to do with
opengl so
i won't be explaining this part and i
actually encourage you to come up with
your own
solution for sorting the windows the
important thing
is that i calculate all the distances
from one window to the camera by
subtracting the window position from the
camera position
and getting the length of that vector
then based on that length
i sort all my windows from the furthest
to the closest and draw them
it's that simple you just have to be a
bit creative with the sorting part
and how you store your object just keep
in mind
that this method where you just draw the
objects in order is not guaranteed to
work
a hundred percent of the time if
different transparent objects
intersect or do some weird stuff you
will get
weird results but other methods are
pretty complicated so for now this will
have to do
in this tutorial i'll show you how to
implement a custom frame buffer into
your opengl application
and how you can use the frame buffer to
achieve post-processing effects
so first of all what is a frame buffer
well you can think of a frame buffer as
a collection of multiple buffers
that result in the final image you see
on your screen
so it contains a color buffer a diff
buffer
and a stencil buffer now why would you
want to use one
well if we create our own frame buffer
then we can display it on a rectangle
that covers the whole screen
and then using shaders modify the pixels
displayed on the rectangle
to achieve different effects this is
called post-processing because you
process the pixels after
all the rendering has already been done
okay now let's implement the frame
buffer
just like any opengl object we create an
unsigned
integer we generate a frame buffer using
glgen frame buffers
and we bind it that was it for the frame
buffer now we need to add a color
texture for it to be of any use
so we'll create a texture just like in
the textures tutorial
making sure we clamp the texture to the
edges
since otherwise certain effects will
bleed from one side of the screen
to the other due to the default
repetition of the texture
then we simply attach the texture to the
frame buffer using gel frame buffer
texture 2d
keep in mind we store our color in a
texture
therefore we can access it from a shader
which we want to do
but in the case of the diff buffer we
don't really care about
reading it in a shader for this tutorial
so instead of using a texture we can use
a render buffer
object which is much faster but has the
disadvantage
that you can't read it directly in a
shader we create it using gel render
buffers
and then we configure its storage using
gel render buffer storage
plugging in gel render buffer gel dev 24
stencil 8
and the width and height we use gel dev
24 stencil 8 so that we can store it in
it
both the stencil buffer and the dev
buffer also be very careful that
all the frame buffers components have
the same width and height
otherwise you might get an error then we
just attach it to the frame buffer using
gel frame buffer
render buffer and for a bit of error
checking
just write this sadly the errors are not
very specific
they just give you a number here are the
meanings of the errors you can get
now that we have our frame buffer object
we can make our rectangle which will
always cover the whole screen
and so we don't want to apply any sort
of transformations to it
now let's create two very basic shaders
from the frame buffer
make them into a shader program and then
send the unit of our texture
0 since it's the only texture in this
shader
now let's handle the drawing part first
we make sure to bind the frame buffer
before we draw
anything including the background make
sure your buffers are cleared
and that you have the testing enabled
after that then
after we are done drawing everything in
the scene we want to switch back to our
default
frame buffer by binding zero and draw a
rectangle which displays the frame
buffer we've just unbinded
just make sure to disable this this
thing so that the rectangle doesn't fill
the def test
now if you run the program you should be
seeing whatever you were seeing before
without any difference if your screen is
a flat color
then first check that you don't have any
errors in your cmd-like window
then make sure your face calling isn't
getting rid of the rectangle so
either change the order of the vertices
or disable calling when drawing the
rectangle
for any other errors check the source
code in the description
and look through your code very
carefully there are a lot of things that
can go wrong
in this case okay now let's make this
interesting
in the frame buffer fragment shader we
can do all kinds of
interesting effects some easy ones would
be inversing the colors like so
or making the image black and white but
these are not that
interesting to get more interesting
results we want to sample multiple
pixels when we choose the color of
a single pixel for that we first want to
declare
an array of vectors which will represent
the offset from the pixel we are on
to its 8 neighbors notice how i divide 1
by 800 to get the width
and height of 1 pixel for my 800 by 800
window
after that we want to create a float
array which will represent something
called a
kernel it's basically a matrix that
helps us achieve cool effects by sort of
defining how
important each pixel is in relation to
the pixel we are currently on
not being the one in the middle
generally speaking you probably want
them to be somewhat symmetrical
and always add up to one if they add up
to more than one
the final color will be brighter and if
they are under one
the final color will be darker here
though they add up to zero
but that is intentional since this is an
edge detection kernel
and i want everything to be really dark
except the edges of things
now all we have to do is to multiply
each part of the kernel with each pixel
at a certain offset and add up all of
them in this vectory named color
just keep in mind that even though these
look like matrices we don't actually
multiply them the same way we do
matrices then the last step is to output
the color as the frog
color and we're done i think this kernel
gives a pretty cool effect
here are some other kernels you might
want to try out i suggest you play
around with this a bit
and make your own kernels so that you
get a feeling as to how they work
in this tutorial i'll show you what cube
maps are in opengl and how you can use
them to create sky boxes
so what are cube maps well there is
simply another type of texture
which holds 6 2d textures one for each
side of a cube
when sampling a cube map you specify a
3d vector
instead of a 2d one this allows you to
easily sample between
all six sides of the cube and since the
coordinates of the cube correspond to
the sampling vectors
there is no need for uvs the most common
uses for cube maps
are quad sphere texturing and sky boxes
so now let's code it in the first thing
you need to do is to write out the cube
vertices
and indices then we'll want to create a
vio
vbo and ebo just like in the first
tutorials
now let's create an array with six
strings that will hold the pass to the
six
images we'll be using for the skybox
then we want to create the cubemap
texture itself just like any other
texture
except that where we put gel texture 2d
before
we now put gel texture cube map make
sure to clump
the texture in all three directions
since the texture is a cube
therefore 3d this clamping should
prevent any seams from showing up
and now we'll go over all six textures
and read them using the sdb library
putting them in the cube texture once we
read them
notice how i disable the vertical
flipping this
is because unlike most textures in
opengl cubemaps are expected to start in
the top
left corner not the bottom left corner
also notice how i add i
to gel texture cube map positive x
this represents the side of the cube i
am currently assigning a texture to
and i am adding i to it in order to
cycle through
all the sides here is the order of the
sides which you can find in the opengl
docs and here is the order we wrote the
pots in
notice something weird well normally in
opengl
the front is in the negative z direction
but for cube maps the front is in the
positive z
direction that means that cube maps work
in a left-handed system
while most of opengl works in a
right-handed system
this can be very confusing and i
honestly have no idea why they chose to
do this
but oh well keep in mind you will likely
get
small bugs because of this if you're not
careful
in my case my right texture kept being
displayed upside down for some reason
to fix that i just flipped the texture
in an
image editor so be prepared for this
sort of stuff
since from what i've heard it can happen
pretty often with sky boxes
okay back to the tutorial we'll now need
to create two setters for the skybox
the vertex shader will take in the
coordinates output texture coordinates
and also take in uniforms for matrix
transformations
in the main function create a vec4 which
holds the final transformed coordinates
now since these coordinates are now in
screen space we'll do something a bit
weird instead of fitting gel position
the coordinates as
they are we'll give it the x y w
and again w components this will result
in the z
component always being 1 after the
perspective division
and since the def buffer takes the zit
component as its depth value
the sky box will always have a dip value
of 1
so the furthest if value possible thus
being behind all
objects as it should be and finally we
want to export the texture coordinates
as the positions except we'll flip the
z-axis to combat the coordinate system
change
for the fragment shader we just want to
import the texture coordinates
the cube map and then set the front
color to equal the texture
that's it back in the main function i'll
create a shader program
and export the skybox texture unit all
that's left
now is the drawing part we'll start by
setting the dev function to
gll equal instead of the default gls
since our skybox is right on the edge
aka 1
so we need that equal sign then we'll
activate the shader and create the view
and projection matrices which are
identical to the ones we created
in the camera class except for one small
detail
for the view matrix we downgrade it to a
mod
3 and then we scale it back up to a mod
4. this will make the last row and
column of the matrix equal to zero
thus having no effect on translations we
only want the skybox to rotate
not move around then simply export these
matrices to the vertex shader
now the final part is to draw the cube
map itself just like any other
object except that when we point the
texture we use gel texture
cube map instead of the usual gl texture
2d
don't forget to switch the depth testing
to its default
gls after you're done with the sky box
if you boot up your program you should
now have a nice sky box
all around you if any of the faces are
inverted or something like that
play around with the orientation of your
images in an image editor
trust me it's a lot easier to just do
that rather than trying to find a little
logic bug
caused by the two different coordinate
systems and the different texture
reading origins
if you have seams that are clearly lines
then you can try adding gel enable gel
texture
cube map seamless somewhere in your code
if your sims are not lines but simply
clear differences in color between one
face and another
then you probably just have a shitty
skybox if you can't see anything or
only parts of the skybox then you
probably have backface calling enabled
and wrote the indices in the wrong
winding order
simply disable face calling when drawing
the skybox
or write the indices in the correct
winding order
in this tutorial i'll show you what the
geometry shader is
and how you can use it to create things
such as visible normals
so far we've only used the vertex shader
and the fragment shader
which suffice in most situations but
sometimes
between the vertex and fragmentators you
want to have an
extra step to modify the geometry of
your meshes
even though it might seem like you can
do that in the vertex shader
you can only do things to individual
vertices
if you wanted to modify a whole triangle
so a
group of vertices then you would need to
use the geometry shader
the second advantage of the geometry
shader is that it can switch between
different types of primitives
and so can create or delete vertices
so let's begin by adding the geometry
shader to our shader class
notice how i am doing the exact same
thing as for the other two shaders
except that i use geo geometry shader
now that we support custom geometry
shaders
let's create a geometry shader that does
nothing
just like in any other shader we'll
begin with a version
then we need two layouts written like so
the first layout signifies what type of
primitive we receive
which can be one of the following while
the second layout
shows what type of primitive we are
outputting
which can be one of the following in
this case we want to receive a triangle
and export a triangle then we have our
outputs to the fragment shader keep in
mind you should pass data from the
vertex shader to the geometry shader
and then to the fragment shader now for
importing data into the geometry shader
we need to do something a bit different
instead of simply having an
in we'll have a sort of c structure
written out like so
notice that we don't have to include the
position in this
because it is already built into a
default structure
just like this one called gel in now we
need to go back to the vertex shader and
replace all the outgoing data with the
exact same structure
except for the last part and out instead
of in
make sure that everything else from the
structure is identical to its
counterpart in the geometry shader
notice how i also included the
projection matrix
that is because we only want to apply
the projection matrix after we modify
our geometry now to assign data to these
outgoing values
we simply write the name we gave them
plus a dot and the name of the variable
we want to assign data to
very similar to a c or c plus plus
structure
now in the geometry shader we have all
the data we need so
all that's left to do is to assemble
these data together
to do that we simply assign the position
normal
color and texture coordinates their data
notice how here i also have an index
besides the name of the part of the
structure
i want to access that's because we are
in the geometry shader and thus we
essentially have an array of such
structures each with different values
for a specific vertex
once we're done assigning the values of
a vertex we must use
emit vertex to declare that we're done
with this vertex vertex vertex vertex
vertex
now we can do the same thing with the
other two vertices and once we're done
with all three vertices we need for a
triangle
we declare that our primitive is
complete using
end primitive and that was it for the
default geometry shader
if you run your program you should have
exactly what you had before
amazing but that's really boring so
let's change things up a bit
and make the geometry shader more fun
something that is extremely easy to do
is to calculate the surface normal using
a cross product
and then add that normal to the three
positions of the primitive
this will make your meshes look as if
all the primitives
exploded or glitched out now let's do
something a bit more serious
let's create a new shader which will
take our default vertex shader
a new fragment shader and a new geometry
shader
and let's draw our model using this
shader after we draw it using the
default shader
now for the fragment shader we'll simply
output the flat color
nothing fancy but for the geometry
shader we'll get a triangle
and output not a triangle but
multiple lines so now we are
actually destroying and creating new
geometry
since as you can see we'll output six
vertices
even though we only got three then we'll
use the exact same structure
and in the main function we'll simply
retrieve the first vertex position
and declare it but then instead of
moving to the next vertex
will remain on this one but add to it
the normal of the vertex
and then emit it this essentially
creates a line across the normal of the
vertex
now we want to do the same for the other
vertices but
in order to not link all the lines
together we must first
end this line by using end primitive and
then move on
after doing this for all the vertices we
can press play
and see that we are now able to
visualize all the normals of our
model which can be pretty useful for
debugging purposes
keep in mind that geometry shooters can
also be very useful for things such as
grass or subdividing models so they're
actually
pretty interesting
in this tutorial i'll show you what
instancing is and how you can use it to
massively improve the performance
and looks of your opengl project so
instancing
is simply a feature that allows you to
draw a mesh multiple times
in a single draw call now why would you
want this
well consider these scenarios where i
have a build of asteroids all made out
of a single asteroid mesh
that is deformed in the vertex shader to
give some variety
in the scenario on the left i simply
have a loop
that draws each asteroid individually so
that means that each asteroid has a
drawcall
now in the scenario on the right i draw
all the asteroids together
so that means that i only have a single
druckle if you look at the performance
difference
you'll see it is massive now let's code
it in
i'll start with the code already written
for the first scenario since it's
nothing new for this series
so in order to enable instancing
all we have to do is to use gel draw
elements
instant instead of gel draw elements
and add at the end of it how many
instances of the mesh we want
the only problem is that this will draw
all the meshes in the exact same
positions
so it is useless there are multiple ways
you could move each mesh to a unique
position though
you could have code that does that in
the vertex shader for example
using gel instance id you'll get the
index of the instance you are currently
drawing
and so you can use that for controlled
random number generation
alternatively you could have a uniform
with all the transformations
and retrieve the correct transformation
for a specific
instance using gel instance id but the
problem with this
is that uniforms can't store that much
data
so the best way to have a lot of
transformations and not have the
generation
inside the vertex shader is to store the
transformations
inside the vertex buffer that is
attached to the vio of the mesh
so let's start by creating a vbo
constructor which takes a vector of
mod force then we want to add an
unsigned
integer public variable to the mesh
class that will signify the amount of
instances we desire
and of course we also need to add it to
the constructor to easily change it
also in the constructor we should add
the vector of matrix transformations for
the instances
so that we can plug it into the vertex
buffer now in the mesh.cpp file we want
to create a vbo for the instances
and then link its attributes to the vio
only if we are drawing more than one
mesh
make sure to link the matrix as four
different fake fours
since otherwise your program won't work
and at the end use
gel vertex attribute divisor plugging in
the layout number of
each vect4 and one this one
means that the vect4 will be used for a
whole instance
if it were 0 then the fake 4 would be
used for
a vertex and then the next big 4 will be
used for the next vertex
which we for sure do not want and just
to make it clear
if it were 2 it would be used for 2
instances before
switching to the next fake four now
let's also limit the use of gel draw
elements instanced
only for multiple instances for the
module class we need to do the exact
same thing as for the mesh class
where we add instance matrix to the
constructor and
as a variable and instancing as a
variable
yet again now in our load mesh function
we want to include
the instancing and instance matrix in
the mesh creation process
now we need a slightly modified shader
for
instance drawing to accommodate for the
new layout
so create a new shader program
specifically for the asteroids using a
special vertex shader
and the default fragment shader the
vertex shader will be
identical to the default one except
we'll have a fifth layout for the
instance matrix
we'll delete the uniforms we don't need
and
replace all transformations with just
the instance matrix one
don't forget to export the lighting
uniforms in the main function
as well then all that's left to do is to
merge the translation rotation and scale
matrices together
and add all of them to the instance
matrix vector
then simply add that and the instancing
number to the model constructor of the
asteroids
and draw the asteroids once remember
that we only need to call the draw
function once
now compile and witness thousands upon
thousands of asteroids with a minimal
performance
impact of course keep in mind that the
performance will differ from one gpu to
another
so it might not work as well on yours as
it would on someone else's
in this tutorial i'll show you what
anti-aliasing
is and how you can implement it in your
opengl project
so you might have noticed that while
horizontal
and vertical edges look extremely crisp
diagonal edges tend to look a bit choppy
like a flight of stairs this is due to
how we display
images on our screens since our displays
are made out of a bunch of tiny squares
aka pixels it is impossible to have a
smooth line
on the diagonal but thankfully we can
fake smoothness
by bleeding the color of an edge into
the adjacent pixels
like so now these jagged edges are
called
aliasing and an anti-aliasing technique
is what helps us get better edges there
are multiple techniques for
anti-aliasing
each with their advantages and
disadvantages but today i'll focus on
msaa which stands for multi-sampling
anti-aliasing so what does this
multi-sampling refer to
well in the rasterization part of the
pipeline primitives are
filled in the way it is decided which
pixels should be given a color and which
should not
is by checking if the sample point of a
pixel
which is normally in the center of it is
inside the shape of the primitive
this means that if the sample point is
even just slightly outside the triangle
it won't get sampled even though you
would think it should at least do so
partially
well that is where msaa comes in
as you might have guessed this technique
simply adds multiple sampling points so
that a more accurate result can be
reached
here for example two of the four
sampling points
are inside the triangle and so the color
of that pixel will be somewhere between
the color of the background
and the color of the primitive now let's
actually
implement this let's start off by
creating a variable
where we specify how many samples we
desire
now if you don't have a frame buffer
then you can just give a window hint to
glfw
saying you want glfw samples and then
the number of samples you want
and then activate jill multi-sample that
was it for this tutorial
as nah i'm joking but for real though
if you don't have a frame buffer then
that's all you have to do
you are done if you do have a frame
buffer then you'll want to delete the
glfw part
instead you need to go to your frame
buffer and replace all
gel texture 2d with gel texture to the
multi-sample
then replace dual text image 2d with
dual text image to the multi-samples
plugging in the type of texture the
number of samples
the color format the width the height
and whether or not
you want all samples to be in the exact
same position in the pixels
then for the render buffer object we
need to change from gel render buffer
storage
to gel render buffer storage
multi-sample
and add the number of samples we want
now the problem is that we can't do any
sort of post-processing on this frame
buffer anymore
since it has multi-sampling enabled so
to get around that we'll need a normal
frame buffer which we can post-process
this is just like the one i made in the
frame buffer tutorial
now in the main function we want to make
sure we first bind the multi-sampling
fbo
clear the screen clear the buffers and
enable depth testing
then we draw everything we want to draw
after that we want the multi-sampling
fbo as read only and the post-processing
fbo as
draw only now using gel bleed frame
buffer
will resolve all the multi-sampling and
copy the result
onto the post-processing fpo now make
sure you bind the default frame buffer
and draw the frame buffer rectangle
using the post-processing texture
run the program and you'll see that the
edges of primitives
are a lot smoother and nicer just be
aware that applying kernels in the
post-processing
will essentially override the
anti-aliasing and so
you may end up with aliasing again as
for the number of samples you should use
i suggest using either 2 4 or 8.
you can go up to 16 and 32 on some gpus
but the improvement over performance
ratio
is not worth it that was it for this
tutorial as
always the source code and all resources
used
are in the description bye